(upbeat music)
- Can I be married to the most
successful supermodel in the world?
- I think it would be much
more fun to be the supermodel.
You get to travel and be creative.
- Then you have to eat
people to kind of sustain
your longevity.
- [Voiceover] Retain your your
- That's true, that's true.
- It's a flip side.
- There's a downside to that.
- Yeah.
- I feel like the agent would
be better for your psyche,
but maybe the supermodel is
better for your bank account?
Maybe!
Maybe not, maybe the agent.
- I would say most successful supermodel
because I love that side of things.
So, I'll go with supermodel, yeah.
- I'll take the supermodel.
- Superhero, for sure.
- Isn't that the same thing?
(laughs)
- I feel like flying is pretty unbeatable.
- Invisibility is, kind
of, that sounds very cool.
I like that.
I'll go with superhero, yeah.
- What about the supermodel superhero?
- I like the future.
I'll do the 16.
- 1996 for sure!
- Maybe '96?
- Oh gosh, 1996.
I think that would, I, yeah.
- I would want to travel anywhere I want.
- Yeah, I would travel everywhere I want,
and then my kids would say stop,
and my wife and I would
go back to the mansion.
- Oh, gosh.
- I guess probably LA
because I like to be grounded
in one place.
- I would travel.
- Oh my god!
Trip.
I wouldn't want to throw up.
Oh my god!
That would, yeah, that
would be very intense.
- Throw up.
That's a statement, that's a statement.
- Everyone trips!
- It's easy, trip is easy.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] You'll
make a name for yourself.
- Exactly, yeah.
- Probably trip.
- Runway because I've done it once,
and there was such an adrenaline
rush that came with it.
- I'd say photoshoot.
- But am I a girl or am I a man?
- [Voiceover] Uh?
Whatever!
- Okay.
- Is that just, just a question?
- Yeah, I mean it's like,
- [Voiceover] Social media,
these supermodels who are men,
they are doing very well.
- Yeah but, not as much fun as a guy.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.